if you're thinking about doing
intermittent fasting and you're hesitant
because it's hard because you're not
eating there's a couple things you can
do to make it easier number one apple
cider vinegar with water if you drink
that couple times a day like a
tablespoon and a glass of water and
drink that you're gonna find your hunger
is going to go away because it actually
helps regulate the blood sugars and it
improves insulin and also a lot of
people are doing like decaf teas warm
teas you can do all different kinds you
know teas that support the liver teas
that support the kidney
another tip would be to make some of
those keto bombs so that way at the meal
you are
really satisfied the other tip would be
to get a little bit more sleep because
when you're tired because you didn't
sleep oh my gosh it really affects your
appetite affects your blood sugars and
it's going to be really hard to do it
and then the last tip would be when
you're eating don't just cram a lot of
food down your throat real fast spend
your time chewing digesting it so that
way you don't add that extra stress down
your stomach